a strike right by the autobahn for
months now employees at this rest stop
have been walking off the job
unannounced for a few hours a day
when they do travelers can't fill up
their cars or get anything to eat or
drink
workers are protesting the low wages
paid by their employer who operates the
service area for burger king and shell
so they can hear you all the way to
italy so you'll no longer be treated
like dirt with such low wages
we don't have to accept this and we
won't accept it
they work as gas station attendants
cooks and cashiers for italian
conglomerate auto grill
normally we're an advertisement for the
firm every day we deal with the
customers we're the contact people for
everyone entering the service area
the firm always says our workers are our
greatest resource
but autograph doesn't want that resource
to cost anything
the work stoppage is costing everyone
plenty
so what do the bosses at auto grill have
to say the operation director for
germany saeed
heads a workforce of fifteen hundred
ahead of last week's strike he drove to
the izanac service area with mixed
feelings
i'm thinking about what could be
awaiting me
and how i can find a solution and calm
the waters
auto grill says it has invested more
than a million euros into the service
area
in 2009 at least the site for 20 years
syed
in milan expect him to deliver results
the expectations are great
it's a balancing act between keeping the
workers happy and offering good service
we're also in the situation of having to
operate 24 hours a day in spite of the
strike
and the present situation
we're doing that partly with our own
employees with workers from other
locations and from the administration
anyone who feels like pitching in at the
front
the head of personnel from frankfurt and
two other managers are here to step in
when the regular workers are striking
they work as cashiers and amateur cooks
all to avoid giving in to the striker's
demands which say torah says are
unjustified
do you pay for vacations and christmas
bonuses yes we do
do you pay bonuses for overtime yes
for night shifts and weekend work
holidays
do you pay more than 70 euros 50.
yes we pay more than 7 euros 50.
an hour
more than 7 euros 50 an hour yes
but that clearly doesn't apply to all
the workers
that colleague is a single mother who
attended university and now works as a
temp for us
she gets seven euros an hour with no
bonus for working sundays holidays or
night shifts seven euros no matter what
so when hatura says workers at the very
bottom of the pay scale get bonuses
that is a bald-faced lie
you're the top wage earner here oh sure
with seven euros an hour and no bonuses
absolutely no of course not
then why work here
i do it on the side i've had a child
ended my studies and i'm looking for a
job so i did this to tide me over during
my studies in parental leave to earn a
bit of extra money
it's really just a bit
one in every three employees here works
part-time or as a temp and like
alexandre lehmann many have worked here
for years she's been a cashier at the
gas station since 2009 and has been a
member of the union for just as long
the 25 year old study business law and
her experiences with auto grill sound
like a textbook case of bad management
during my pregnancy auto grill wanted to
throw me out but i fought back and with
the njj
the union
yeah
a day before the hearing they withdrew
the dismissal and said it was all a
mistake and i wasn't fired
maybe she'll win the wage battle too by
having the courage to fight back